Pewds: Hows it goin' bros...
Ma name is Pewdiepie
Pewds : Uhh...
Pewds : So today...
Pewds : I was going to play a game with Marzia...
Pewds: but she's not available...
Pewds : Sooo Uhmm...
'Marzia': Bruh!...
Marzia : Felixx !!
Pewds: Marzia?
'Marzia': I'm available bruh!
Pewds: (Laughs) Oh I'm sorry
Pewds: I didn't realize...
Pewds : You were here !
You look... goo..good
*sax music*
Don't ! Please... (laughs)
Were you going to let me motorboat you?
'Marzia': Bruh, you wanna motorboat? (poses)
(Pewds laughs increasingly more uncomfortably)
*more sax music*
*nip slip*
Pewds: nooo... well... you can't do that on YouTube..
Marzia!
'Marzia': Bruh
Pewds: (shushes) My mum is watching...  please... come on...
'Marzia': My mum is watching too!
Marzia: Italia Pewds: We suppose... Italia.. okay..
Pewds: But we're gonna play a game called push me, push you...
Pewds : Its just come out...
Pewds : Its really cool, I think you're really gonna like this game
Marzia: We played this...
Marzia : In uhh...
Marzia : In bed
Pewds: So in this game...
Pewds : Ahh its kinda like cat dog
Pewds : And I'll be the cat and you'll be the dog
Marzia: What is catdog?
Pewds: Catdog is the cartoon from the nin...
Marzia: I'm from Italy, they don't have a cartoon..
Pewds: Okay
Pewds : Well...
Pewds : I'm gonna be...
Pews : Ahh..
Pewsd : The one on the left..
Pewds : Okay so I'm
Pewds : I'm the bald guy...
Marzia: You like my hair ?
Pewds : Yeah , no , you look good...
Marzia: You like it ??
Pewds : Yeah , you look ... you look really good ...
Marzia : Its change for you ?
Pewds : No , it looks the same
Marzia : You like my breast ?
Pewds : If you had any * triggered *
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOHHHH
( lol Marzia's face )
Pewds : Okay
Pewds : Ahh...
Pewds : My hair is bacon
Marzia : Which... which one look like my hair ?
Pewds : That one
Marzia : Alright , its important !
Pewds ; Yeah I know it is
Marzia : This is the type of thing that Marzia actually does
Pewds : Yeah , I know it is...
Brad : Uh huh...
Brad : Sorry mate
* Pewds proscessing *
Pewds : Okay , so I am this guy
Pewds : On the left
Marzia : Omg it is so creepyyy...
Pewds : Yes... They're...(laughin)
Pewds : Yes , that is creepy alright
Pewds : Oh I'm so tiny ...
Marzia : Wierdest thing...
Pewds : Urgg ...
Marzia : Ouuch ...
Marzia : How did you do this ...
Pewds : Urrggg ...
Marzia : UUUUURRRGGG
Pewds : Uh huh ...
Pewds : Okay pink team ...
Pewds : Keep the ball on here ...
Pewds : Purple team keep the ball on here ...
Pewds : Okay
Marzia : Alright which one am I ?
Pewds : You are the purple team
Marzia : Keep the ball on my own side or yours ?     Pewds : Yeah
Pewds : Yeah , no my side , your side ...
Pewds : No , its my ball
Marzia : Stay away...
Marzia : Yayyy got you caught too...
Marzia super cute laugh : ha ha ha
Pewds : Wtf ...
Pewds : Marzia please ...
Marzia : How dare you ?
Pewds : Marzia I have to win !
Pewds : I am the man !
Pewds : Fuck sake ...
Pewds : Ohh !
Pewds : Oh you got a point ... fuck it ..
Pewds : Can you sto...    Marzia : YEEEAAAAHHHHH
Pewds : Ohhh it's on my side now Marzia !!
Pewds : What you gonna do bout det
Marzia : I will steal the ball back ...
Pewds : Aw really ?
Marzia : You have to let me
Marzia : You're not allowed to bully me I am your girlfriend !
Pewds : MA BALL !
Marzia : Your balls from you !!
Pewds : AWWW
Marzia : Yeah I got it !
Pewds : NO !
Marzia : Look at dis !
Pewds : Give me ma balls back !
Pewds : Why are you legitimately good at this game for once ?
Pewds : Oh ...
Pewds : Come on
Pewds : Get in here !
Marzia: I am not suspiciously better today
marzia : There we go ..
Marzia : I get another point !
Pewds : Fuck you Marzia !
Marzia : UUHHHHHHHHHHOOO
Marzia : YEEEEAHHHHH ! ( like a man )
Pewds : How does your voice feel Marzia ?
Marzia : It is actually really hurt every time I have to do this ...
Marzia : But its worth it because ...
Marzia : Because my fans are watching CutiePie
Marzai : CutiePies
Pewds : All your CutiePies are watching yeah ...
Pewds : Yeah you're right ...
Marzia : I have the ball
pewds : Ahh forr fuck sake ...
Marzia : You do no...
Pewds : Aww I'm doin...
Pewds : I beat at your owwn game Marzia !
( can't hear the fuk is Marzia talkin about )
pewds : Let me push you ...
( Sound of Pewds and Marzia cuddling )
Pewds : YEAAAAAHHHH
Pewds : No Marzia please...
pewds : Don't be sad
Marzia : You make a me crya Pewds !
( Italian ?? )
Marzia : Don't spray my niaepples !!
Marzia : My new hairstyle is all ruined...
Marzia : ...a now...
Pewds : Don't be sad Marzia ...
Pewds : You're so beautiful !
Marzia : Just like the scene in the Notebook when its a ...
Marzia : Crying !
Marzia : Have you seen the film The Notebook when a ...
Pewds : I have seen The Notebook
Marzia : Kissing in the rain ?
Pewds : You just distracting me from losing...
Pewds : No , for fuck ... please ...
Pewds : Please jusst get off me !
Marzia : You are getting rekt at this game bro ...
Pewds : Fuckin let go...
Pewds : What ??
Marzia : Rekt noob...
Marzia : What ... Yeah !!
Marzia : YEAH !!
Marzia : Your time to cry bitch !
Marzia : Yeah thats right !
Pewds : Ahh I'm so sad !
Marzia : You fuckin cry ...
Pewds : I'm so sad !
Mrrzia : You fuckin cry bitch !
Pewds : Marzia please !
Marzia : YEAH !!!
Marzia : Cry more bitch !
Pewds : I'm so sorry
Marzia : Crying all the tears I'll lick'em up !
Marzia : Just need to cover my nipples again ...
pewds : Hey cover your self up what the fuck is wrong with you ?
Marzia : I will blurr them !
Pewds : Omg
Marzia : You don't like them ??
Pewds : No , I don't like them
Pewds : Are they real ?
Marzia : Yeah you want to lick it ?
Marzia : Forr the views ...
Marzia : You can never come back from this ...
Pewds : I consider it for like the fun but ...
Pewds : ... but no I'm not fuckin do that shit !
Marzai : You can never come back !
Pewds : You would let me do it thats the fuckin weird part dude !
Pewds : MUUUUUUUAAAAAARRRRR
Marzia : MUUUUUUUUAAAAAAARRRR
Marzia : I haven't seen you since the war ...
Pewds : Well ... I wrote you every single day !
Pewds : Lets hug and kiss
Pewds : MUUUUUAAARRRR
Marzia : MUUUUUAAAAARRRR
Marzia : I love you so maaach !
Pewds : I love you too Marzia !
Pewds : Ohhhhh the love is so strong !
Pewds : Ohhh we're circle ...
Pewds : We're snail !
Pewds : Who ever wins this one ...
Mariza : Will be the dominate one to night ...
Marzia : Okay
Pewds : Uh huh
Marzia : And I will let you win
Marzia : I would like to be dominated by you for once you litte hoe...
Marzia : you can not TAKE THIS BALL !!
Pewds : Nahh its my ball Marzia
Pewds : You know that ...
Pewds : We talked about the balls Marzia
Marzia : No they are mY balls
Pewds : Oh yeah you're right ...
Marzia :That is how this relationship work
Pewds : That is how , you have my balls, you're right
Marzia : Thats how this whole relationship work
Pewds : Oh Marzia let me touch you
Pewds : Come on Marzia let me touch you ...
Marzia : You can not touch me without my consent
Pewds : C'mon Marzia !
Marzia : Don't touch me !
Pewds : Thats how its done Marzia !
Marzia : NO ! No !
Pewds : I'll get a new girlfriend if you don't win this game ...
Marzia : You sould not joke about that stuff Pewds ...
Pewds : I'm sorry ... I'm sorry (x3) ... come back and play
Pewds : You're letting me win !
Marzia : No !!!
Pewds : YEAH !
Marzia : This is unfair !
Pewds : YEAAAH !
Marzia : You cheated !!
Marzia : You said real life painful thing to me !
Pewds : I'm , I'm sorry , don't be  ...
Marzia : My nipples are coming out again !
Pewds : No !
Pewds : Just cover yourself up !
Marzia : I'm trying !
Pewds : Cover yourself woman
Marzia : I'm trying to recover again ...
Pewds : Alright , L ... l ... last chance Marzia ...
Marzia : No I'm winning ...
Pewds : Are you really tho ... ?
Marzia : Yes !
Pewds : Are you really tho ?
Pewds : Are you ...
Pewds : Oh you are ...
Pewds : How do you WIN at this game ?
Marzia : Coz I am so good at video games all of a sudden ...
Pewds : YEAH !!!
Marzia : H...hey !
Marzia : Hey !
Pewds : Ahhh
Marzia : No bro you ruined it
Pewds : Yeah BRO !
Pewds : YEAH BRO !
Marzia : Felix!
Pewds : Yeah whatsup ?
Marzia : Stop !
Pewds : Yep
Pewds : Stop what ?
Marzia : You're nasty !
Pewds : You're not my girlfriend
Marzia : Look !
pewds : You're not ... Oh god !
Marzia : You're being pushed away ...
Pewds : No ... no ... no , nonononono ...
Marzia : Yeah I'm gonna win !
Marzia : Back in to the purple !
Pewds : No , not a ... back in !!
Marzia : Back into the purple !
Pewds : Come on !
Marzia :YEAAAH
Pewds : NOOOOOO !!!
Marzia : YEAAAAAAHHHHHUHHHH
Marzia : Waaahaaaa !!
( wtfukkk ??? )
Pewds : Shame on you !
Pewds : Shame on you !!
Marzia : Do I look like the girl from The Ring ?
Pewds : You do !
Marzia : Did you like my make up today ?
Pewds : Uhh, Yeah , you look really good ...
Marzia : I get my self a nice jawline ...
Marzia : Contour
Pewds : Yeah , I know , its nice !
Pewds : You might wanna ...
pewds : Uhmm ...
Pewds : Nothin ...
Marzia : You think I look beautiful ?
Pewds : Yes
Marzia : You like meeee ?
Pewds * wtf * ofcourse ...
Marzia : Who won ?
Pewds : I did ...
Marzia : Who won overall ?
Pewds : I did
Marzia : Who won your heart ?
Marzia : You did
Marzia : Okay so I can go now ?
Pewds : Okay
Pewds : Yeah now we could ...
Marzai : I'm hungry ...
Pewds : Yeah ...
Marzia : We need to feed Puga
Pewds : Okay ...
Pewds : Alright...
pewds : We need to feed Puga !
Pewds : Thank you for watching this video so much ...
Pewds : Leave a ...
Pewds : Leave a like ?
Marzia : Leave a like
Marzia : It really helps out of this channel ...
Marzia : Thank you for your subscribe ...
Marzia : You can check out my channel ...
Marzia : CutiepieMarzia
Pewds : CutiepieMarzia
Marzia : Thank you for ...  as always
Pewds : And as always ...
Marzia: My beard is all wet and gross from the the tears..